oh mein gott das ist einfach schwierig
zu sagen dass daran jetzt falsch
aussieht weil es erkennt jeder auf den
ersten blick das stimmt einfach nicht
[Musik]
leute das letzte mal habe ich hoffe die
krassesten visual effects cgi sachen
reagiert und das sag ich mir nicht
hergeben auch die schlechteste und sagen
weil man müsste eigentlich meinen so
hollywood filmstudios sind ultra krass
was das angeht aber um eine verkappte
filmstudios das einfach auch heute noch
deswegen ja direkt mal rein okay wir
fangen hier einmal mit matrix reloaded
aus dem jahr 2003 da kennt natürlich
jeder dieses eine battle mit agent smith
und leona wo dann einfach die leute so
ultra komplett unrealistisch
herumschweben wo dann gefühlt jeder an
einem seil dran hängt einerseits hier
zum beispiel also in dieser szene ist
natürlich real und das sieht ja auch
natürlich dementsprechend real aus aber
ihr das sehen ja so vorsieht man diese
ganzen 3d animierten und das erkennt man
auch überfallen mit dem schotter sieht
man wiederum pflegt eine gummipuppe hört
sich natürlich absolut nicht viel aus
dann in den shop wo er jetzt plötzlich
real ist wo man dann viel mehr details
in seinem gesicht wider merkt man
natürlich direkt aus der davor nicht
echt war also nicht nur wie die aussehen
sondern auch die bewegungen von den
inhalt komplett wird und die fliegenden
warum wieso komische gummipuppen
ja nur dafür passt sich jetzt der neo
und hier in dem shop sind die leute und
imperial hat der schauspieler sich
einfach an verschiedene produktionen
gestellt und dann haben die dänen daraus
maskiert oder vielleicht im green screen
gearbeitet der ist auf jeden fall rein
oder erkennt man auch auf jeden fall den
unterschied dann am legend da man ist
natürlich diese legendären zombie der
einfach also tut mir leid ich verstehe
heute technisch weil die haben halt das
ultra classic budget bei so einem film
und haben auch die geilsten leute die
daran arbeiten ich weiß nicht was
passieren kann dass die ja das ist dann
einfach aus wie aus einem computerspiel
von der playstation 2 aussieht ich will
jetzt ja gar nicht so arrogant gegen
unser gehörig kurz besser kann ich kann
ich wahrscheinlich nicht aber da
arbeiten halt hunderte leute dran die
ultra viel budget haben deswegen
irgendwann irgendwas ist das
schiefgegangen
indiana jones ok was haben wir hier was
okay der bruder der alien der alien hier
passt gar nicht zu dieser umgebung ein
das sieht man einfach gar keine details
auf seiner haut er sieht einfach aus wie
komplett plastik zu würde aber dieses
licht da hinten des lichtes wird sich
nicht so verhalten wenn der hintergrund
an der stelle so dunkel ist deswegen
sieht das hier einfach komplett anders
und was ist also was du so wirklich fast
das da ist es das sieht einfach aus als
hätten liegt die aus wachs nachgebaut
und daneben abgeschmolzen und dann hier
so ein richtig guter ist visionär wollen
daher an alle drei filme habe ich gar
nicht gesehen
diese fand hier aus die welt diese
eisberger peter sieht die richtig
schlecht aus oh mein gott das ist das
schlechteste grünen das ist
wahrscheinlich dass green screen ich
jemals gesehen habe und auch jeder
schatten auf dem wasser willst du hier
ultraviolet auszahlung aus dem jahre
2006 habe ich auch nicht gesehen okay
das also dass also tut mir da das sieht
echt aus das sie investiert was hat das
denn gut noch mal ganz kurz wo wir das
motorrad herunter fällt da ist einfach
nur gravitation das 0 was ist das denn
für ein fall
was ist das denn so zerfällt motor dann
einfach nicht weil eigentlich fallen
sachen ja so dass die erst ganz langsam
fahren und dann halt ganz schnell
schneller werden gravitation kennt man
und dann hätte so theoretisch auch eine
geschmeidige fall kurve und da ist es
hat irgendwie so das geht dann zu boden
und bleibt bestehen und dann so sagt es
fliegt es auch hier jetzt bei dieser
explosion
das wird noch mal komplett anders
aussehen weil diese expansion im hintern
also derartig hell ist dass da
eigentlich dieses licht von der
explosion der kein brennen würde quasi
an den rändern von ihr und außerdem ist
die explosion natürlich nicht unbedingt
realistisch weil das ist halt normal
holte heiß und durch diese hitze fängt
die luft natürlich an diese ganze sache
beenden zu verzehren und das haben sie
ja auch nicht gemacht dieser explosion
ist einfach komplett komplett fake aus
und das liegt einfach daran war eine
explosion hat ultra hell ist in echt und
die dann eigentlich überbelichtet zahlen
müsste und wenn quasi in einem videoclip
wenn man es wirklich filmen würde wenn
er diese sachen so helfen wo die sonne
da links an dieses gebäude heran scheint
nur wenn die sache so hell sind dann
müssen auf jeden fall die explosion
deutlich heller sein als die stelle die
wir allein von der sonne angestrahlt
wird und dementsprechend sieht das
einfach richtig fake aus und jetzt man
kennt ihn den guten alten scorpion king
aus die mumie und da sieht er den rock
versieht ich kann es nur beschreiben die
computer spielt hier diese reflexion auf
seiner stirn zum beispiel die seen in
echt einfach nicht so aus tut mir leid
bruder du hast halt eigentlich
eigentlich hat so ein mensch halt auch
viel mehr struktur an sich und ist nicht
so ein glatter kopf da ist viel mehr
text uhr da sind wir unter allen
ungereimtheiten auf eine haut drauf da
sind mal so minimale schuppen was ich
drauf die dann quasi das licht so ein
bisschen anders reflektieren und der
sieht an sich viel zu gut aus was das
angeht dann ist vielmehr reflektionen
auf seine auf seinem gesicht drauf sein
aber mit reflexion ist also ein bisschen
schwierig weil man zu viel reflexion
drauf hat einfach über alles drauf dann
sieht das einfach aus wie plastik und
wenn man zu wenig drauf hat dann sieht
es auch nicht geil aus kunst ist es halt
die ganzen spiegelungen und reflexionen
und licht scheine und alles mögliche an
die richtigen stellen dran zu bekommen
da wo sie eben auch in der realität
werden durch die ganze physikalischen
regeln und das dank war sie so nah zu
machen ist die kunst und das ist hier
auf jeden fall nicht unbedingt gelungen
da und hier auch richtig richtig
gefährlich wo er so ganz meine kamera
ankommen wo man halt komplett erkennt
bruder
es hat einfach ein 15-jähriger mit paint
immer hier sieht man es richtig gut im
vergleich also man sieht hier ist quasi
das gesicht von dem echten schauspieler
so richtig reflektion der schweiz sah
ich direkt drauf 90 minuten perfekt
glatt plastik gesicht von diesem 3d
modell
wo auch generell auf den scorpion king
es viel zu wenig kontrast ja man sieht
ja richtig wie dunkel oder die schwarz
dass wir schwarz wäre quasi von dem
echten schauspieler sind und wie bereite
ich was sie für einen rotstich haben bei
diesem scorpion king auch bei dem
kollegen hier da sieht man ja bei dem
bad bei den spiegelungen so das sind
details drin da sind poren da sind
uneben halten da rumpelt sich mal eine
nase da sieht man einfach das ist ein
mensch so die augen spiegeln richtig und
das sieht man halt
sieht man einmal von dem scorpion king
nicht und was der rücken da soll das
weiß ich auch nicht hier dragonheart die
anfänglich gar nicht gesehen haben aber
man sieht hier zum beispiel dass dieser
drache der passt farblich dann begann
ich rein der summe viel zu roth da passt
der weißabgleich einfach nicht diese
reflektion hier auf diesem hohen eine
reflexion dieses also so helle reflexion
des wassers jeweils in bild muss halt in
der regel ein beweis sein sonst ist
einem farbstich drin man sich natürlich
auch bei den kontakt zwischen wasser und
rache da sieht man halt auch dass da
einfach dass eine komplett glatte kanten
ist und dass eben jetzt nicht irgendwie
so nicht ist und alles mögliche und man
sieht wie sie versucht haben eine gift
und schauen hin zu machen aber ist da
nicht mehr vergangen muss man einfach
sagen film ist schon uralt hierzu man
sieht da dachte ich eigentlich denn zum
ersten mal gesehen habe vor einigen
jahren dass der ultra geil ist und echt
für 1995 ist auch dass er die sachen
aber wenn man sich so was heute an
gruppen und vielleicht planet der affen
schon mal gesehen hat dann weiß man gut
eigentlich sollte das vielleicht ein
bisschen besser aus als coupe oh oh mein
gott das ist einfach schwierig zu sagen
dass daran jetzt falsch aussieht weil es
erkennt jeder auf den ersten blick das
stimmt einfach nicht der hat es sieht
einfach nicht echt was wie das
langgezogene wir nochmal müssten da
diese wie sich haut und sowas grätscht
da verändert sich die komplette text uhr
eigentlich und da wir jetzt mal einfach
nur entlang gezogen wenn sie so eine
haut die neben dann gehen sich die haut
auch so eine art reise wo dann quasi
diese reflexion bei der haut komplett
ein anderes muster ergeben und wie ist
da eben jetzt da er lang gezogen wird
das sieht dann einfach so aus na ja und
das in die realistisch aus hier haben
die x-men origins drin und jetzt will
ich mal wissen weil ex mann ist einer
meiner lieblings reihen ok ja gut da
hätte man die reflektion und dieses die
spiegelung von diesen krallen hätte man
wieder machen können aber ansonsten ja
ist ok der hobbit hier mal gucken was
sie da verpackt haben das finde ich
eigentlich voll stark will ich auch voll
okay finde ich gar nicht schlecht
gemacht und dann haben wir den guten
sonic darauf wurde ich so oft
hingewiesen dass das uvek ist dass ich
mich dann angerufen soll
ok also an sich finde ich da jetzt von
von dem cgi so gar nicht schlecht also
dieses diese reflektion ist okay ja so
ein bisschen zu gesättigt aber ich
glaube es tatsächlich gemacht sondern
mit deshalb ein bisschen sonne
freundlicher wirkt so und an sich finde
ich jetzt den sonne gar nicht schlecht
von von realismus her quasi vom raus
rändern hier aber vom 3d modell von
modeling finde ich ein bisschen strange
dass sich diese proportionen die passen
halt einfach gar nicht die passenden
immer mal gar nicht
die wollten den halt zu machen wieso
einen echten menschen ich finde dadurch
geht viel verloren ganz kurz irgendwas
gesicht ja also die augen die sind ja
besonders mal komplett anders aber ich
glaube da sitzt der da kam der lage mich
daran dass es ja sowieso schlecht
rausgerechnet wissend dass die
reflektion und der schatten nicht stimmt
sondern wir das 3d modell und diese das
charakter design macht einfach nicht
passen ich bin hier mal ein elvis der
wie sonic aus triesen schuhe der hat
hier sucht dieses visier als augen dann
hat er diesen hände
das passt nicht zusammen und ich glaube
deswegen haben die leute ausgerichtet
okay wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt okay so
schwer kann das auch nicht sein ich will
so etwas auch werden und auch die reise
der digitalen kunst antreten dann kann
ich mich empfehlen da nicht unbedingt
direkt mit 3d animation oder so
anzufangen sondern mitschnitt der sind
guter einstieg in diese kreative welt
dann kann ich euch mal einen schnittkurs
empfehlen die zwei stunden lang wo ich
extrem gut strukturiert was man da alles
werden kann und in einzelnen
unterkategorien ist alles untergliedert
hat von dem bild zahlt natürlich noch
einmal nicht monatlich und könnte den
kurs oft angucken wie er möchte den kurs
ist auch schon filmmaterial dabei was
ich in norwegen gefilmt habe damit könnt
ihr dann gerne arbeiten den link dazu
findet ihr eine video beschreibung
folgten unbedingt auf insgesamt waren
dafür tue ich mit solchen instagram
stories und halten euch auf dem
laufenden was gerade so macht auch oft
sei mäßig und für meine videos und wenn
er mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte der abonniert doch die an diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst mal
wieder ganz gut
[Musik]